ces exercices de frappe museler sont
réalisés tous les mardis après midi par
l'association cynophile de police
municipale créée en 2011 par hervé un ex
policier de la police municipale
d'elancourt cette association permet de
former les maîtres chiens elle fait donc
ses 10 ans
l'occasion de remettre un présent à la
mairie d'elancourt qui a oeuvré à son
développement
j'étais vraiment à nous accompagner du
début parce que quand tu auras un
terrain où mettre à disposition un
terrain sani une somme c'est c'est un
investissement
les séances d'entraînement s'organise en
trois étapes une première partie
obéissance et sociabilité avec de la
marche au pied puis une deuxième phase
avec des exercices en situation je
m'équipe d'un plastron d'un d'un gilet
renforcé d'un casque pour protéger mon
visage et puis le maître chien on voit
son chien il est le chien équipé d'une
muselière de frappe d'un collier et d'un
harnais et puis l'on voit le chien en
légitime défense on va dire sur une
agression que que je simule enfin
troisième phase la partie mordante
le chien et délices les ai envoyées à la
caq des situations que les maîtres
chiens sont amenés à vivre sur la voie
publique
voilà il ya des collègues sur des
interventions qui sont tombés qui ont
pris des coups elle même avec leur chien
donc pouvoir réagir avec le chien qui
c'est qui qui reprend le chien en relais
qu'on commence place et chansons pour la
majorité des bergers belges malinois
berger allemand au rottweiler des races
plus prêts destinés au travail frédéric
a intégré la brigade de nuit d'elancourt
il a un chien personnel qu'il vient
service de la collectivité
quand j'ai eu la chance d entre eux
police municipale j'ai toujours voulu
allier sa passion pour les chiens avec
mon travail dans la police
donc c'est pour ça que des fûts en 2014
dans mon chien et contre commencé ma
formation en tant que maître chien et
poursuit dans ce milieu en dix ans
l'association a formé plus de 50 mètres
chien d'ile-de-france d'art et loire et
d'indre et loire